hey there my name is cameron and you are
watching motion science and today we
are talking about how to build
this
so as you can see it's a very visually
interesting
animation motion design piece and it's
created using
3d camera uh 3d layers and
textures and some really interesting
visual effects shots from our friends at
action
vfx so let's dive in and let's create it
let's start by
bringing this image here and you can see
that this is an
image from i believe it's world war ii
and i found this on the internet it's a
free creative commons image i've used it
before in another
online course i taught and i really just
am drawn to this image i think it's just
a
very emotional
piece and i really just want to bring
some life to it so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna make it a 3d layer
i'm going to go to layer new camera
and i'm going to select 35 millimeter
make sure depth of field is turned
off and maybe push in a little bit here
something like so so we have a little
bit of room to work with our 3d camera
so we've got some edges here
i'm going to set a keyframe for position
and we're going to
hit c on our keyboard kind of move this
image maybe up in here
go to the end of our timeline here and i
should mention this is a
1920 by 1080 comp 24 frames per second
five seconds
long click ok and then here at the end
we're going to just kind of
move down in here so we've got this kind
of
interesting movement here and
you know it's not that interesting to
start off with so
what can we do to make this a little bit
more interesting well what we can do is
we can have to parallax to the shot
by kind of dividing this shot up into
three different sections what i see here
is i see a foreground which is our boat
i see a middle ground here which is the
water with the soldiers in the water and
i see a background which is this beach
and these clouds up in here
so let's jump into photoshop
and let's cut this image apart
so here i am in photoshop and when i'm
cutting images out in photoshop i like
to use the pen tool
it's the tool that i've always used i
like to zoom in as much as possible on
an image
and get as much detail as possible when
i'm cutting an image out it's all about
those
little details and when you're cutting
something out like this you may think
like well i don't need to probably cut
out this
line with this hook on the end of it you
know they're not going to notice that
different you know if it's there or not
there but i'm telling you they will
notice this
the client will or whoever you're trying
to show this to so
i like to get as much detail in my
cutouts as possible
sometimes i'll i'll be cutting along and
get a wrong area like right here
where i'm getting a soldier cut out with
a boat and i back up i'm like okay undo
that
and i just control z control z back it
out
zoom back in and continue to cut the
boat out an image like this
i'm looking at a foreground a middle
ground and a background
the more layers you create the more
parallax you can actually create
but three layers is typically enough a
foreground middle ground and background
here i am cutting out the parts of the
image that shouldn't be included
so again just finding the areas where
i need to cut out like the water here
from the boat
inside this these little hooks again
it's all about the details
you know very small little areas but it
makes a big difference when you go to uh
animate this in after effects so here i
am uh creating a path
i like to give it a little bit of a
feather like one pixel feather
and then duplicating the layers making a
middle ground and a background
and just using the eraser tool to erase
the foreground here uh so that this can
be part
of the background and then using like
the clone stamp tool and
zooming in again and getting as much as
close as we can
into some detail it doesn't have to be
perfect for what we're doing here
uh you're going to notice some
imperfections in the clouds there but i
just
select an area and kind of just paint
and just remove areas of the image
just to create a believable background
and then we're going to create the
middle ground here
we're going to erase the background like
so with the eraser tool
erase the foreground right in here
and then we've got this middle ground
and we need to give us more detail
without that boat so again i'm using the
clone
stamp tool and just trying to give it
some some area here to work with if
we're not careful when we do parallax
like this
you can see overlapping foreground
background elements
so this isn't a tutorial about uh
cutting this stuff out but i just wanted
to show you this
very simple process next we're gonna
move back in
to after effects
okay so we're back here in after effects
we've got our image cut apart i've got
it imported in i brought it in as a
composition
where i retained the layer sizes and you
can see the layers are here
background boat middle and if i double
click on this
composition here i've got the three
layers just like we had in photoshop
right we've got the background the
middle ground and the boat
so what we want to do here is we want to
go back into our comp select our
original photoshop layer and we want to
replace this
with our pre comp so i'm going to hold
down alt or option
and i'm going to drag down here and
replace
and just let go and it replaces so it
looks exactly the same
but now we have a precomp here okay so i
can double click this pre comp
come in here and again it looks the same
but we've got layers here so what do we
need to do we need to
separate these layers we need to make
them 3d
so i'm going to select the 3d button
here hit p for position
and i am going to separate them i have
80d when it comes to
working with numbers in 3d space like
this so i like to be even so i'm going
to take the background
back to a thousand pixels one zero zero
zero
and the middle ground i'm going to go to
500 pixels
just like that and i'm leave the
foreground the boat
just like it is if i switch to two views
horizontal here
you can see here's the the boat
here is the middle ground and here's the
background
okay so we can see kind of like what's
going on here now
what we need to do here is separating
these layers in 3d space they just look
strange right we need to fill in the
gaps here so what we need to do is we
need to scale up
this background so we're going to do
that first we're going to hit s for
scale and we're just going to scale this
guy up
just like so and let's hit shift p for
position
and let's bring up this layer here
something like this and i'm actually
going to go ahead and increase the size
again
so that we have more room to work with
so let's go up to
somewhere about right there i select the
middle ground it's already at 500 pixels
hit shift s for scale and we are going
to scale
this one up as well
something about oh about right here
and i think that's good and the boat's
looking pretty good as well
and i think that's going to work for
what i'm trying to do here so now let's
just go back to our original camera move
here and see
what we have and it still looks exactly
the same right even though this is a 3d
layer it looks exactly the same
so that is because this pre comp
is not being viewed as a as a true 3d
layer with with
as a true pre-comp with 3d layers inside
of it so if i go to two views here
and i zoom in you can see here is that
pre-comp and it's
a flat layer but if we go back into our
pre pre-comp and we go to two views
you can see we have a foreground and
middle ground and background so how do
we make
the foreground middle ground and
background come through on
our precomp here it's really easy all we
have to do is click this button right
here
and as soon as i do that you can see
the the bounding box gets bigger here
and the image changed over here so this
is without
just a flat image collapse we've got a
foreground a middle ground
and a background go back to one view
here
and now if we move through this now you
can see
that parallax that we were going for
okay
so one thing i want to do here looking
at this is i want to i think
reverse the move i want it to kind of
come downwards versus
up so i'm going to take both these
keyframes here the first one the second
one
and i'm going to right click keyframe
assistant
time reverse keyframes boom so now our
our move is backwards okay and like i
said it looks a little bit weird
up in up in here but we can do some
things to kind of
hide that later on here so that looks
pretty cool
i'm liking that so far uh so next let's
bring in some
some elements here from action vfx okay
so
again remember that our background is
positioned back at
1000 pixels that is our background area
here
and let's bring in some action vfx
visual effects footage i love the the
fiery smoke plumes that you see here
i've also got some close fog but let's
start
with bloom number four let's bring them
down here
and immediately you know just looks
terrible let's make it 3d
not that the footage looks terrible just
in the composition i mean i love this
footage it's great
hit p for position i'm gonna hit zero
i'm gonna turn that to 1000 so now this
footage is pushed back
in space and i'm going to scale this
down a little bit
let's go down to a number something like
this
and kind of position it up here
something like so so now when we move it
kind of looks like that footage is
sitting back there
in the background which is cool i like
that now the footage does not look like
it blends in
to the photo so we need to do some
compositing
to fix that so what we're gonna do next
is we're gonna go to effect
let's go to color correction black and
white
to make it black and white that's a good
start next let's go to effect
blur and sharpen gaussian blur
and let's give it a blur of about
three pixels so that's with and without
it's very subtle maybe a little bit more
maybe five
maybe seven
maybe seven did i just rotate that on
accident i think i did yes i did
let's go back and rotate that uh maybe
seven maybe that's too much but
we'll come back to it next we're gonna
go to effect color correction curves
and let's just bump up
those gray values there so you can see
by doing that it kind of brings it into
this world here
so that's without and that's width and
maybe a little bit more i never get
super precise
uh when it comes to working with color
and that's one of those maybe that's a
downfall of mine but you know i do just
enough to make it work
so i think that's going to work just
fine for me
next let's bring in another piece of
footage here let's go with
maybe number six and actually before we
do that let's undo that let's just
duplicate
this fiery plume four and let's go back
to number six
and we're gonna hold down alt or option
click and drag to replace
and maybe bring this guy over here and
yeah that's pretty cool i like that a
lot
let's kind of work on the positioning
here a little bit
let's bring down the scale maybe
55 make it a little bit smaller
yeah i like that that's looking pretty
cool
awesome let's go ahead and duplicate
again so command d
to duplicate and let's bring in we've
got four
six let's bring in number ten alter
option click or drag to bring it down
oh yeah i like that one a lot we're
gonna bring this now because we
separated we took the time to separate
these layers in photoshop
i'm able to bring this layer behind the
boat here and it kind of just sits back
there which is really nice
gives it some extra realism
yeah i'm really digging that a lot i
could always you know play around with
the the start point
of this footage maybe dragging this out
a little bit
i really like the the plume that happens
here gives a lot of
motion to this piece that doesn't exist
because it says
uh still photography so that works
pretty well
uh cool okay so what can we do next to
make this even look
better right let's start bringing in
some textures let's lay them over the
top let's give it even more
depth uh and to do that we're gonna go
into our textures here
and we're gonna find this image right
here uh
which i can't remember where i got this
but i want to say it was probably off
the web and let's go ahead and scale
this
up something like so let's make it 3d
so it reacts to the camera and let's go
ahead and
drag it down here and let's just make
sure that it's inside
the image the entire the inside the
camera frame i don't want to see any
edges like we just saw
right here so let's make sure it's
covered there
let's go back yes we need to scale it up
just a little bit more
maybe something like this
perfect love it so let's hit toggle
switches modes
let's go back to our mode and let's go
to add
and yeah you can see like i mean it just
it created some really interesting
some depth there but you know what can
make it even more interesting
so that's not kind of sitting on the
same plane as our boat
because you can see like if you were to
look at like look at this scratch right
here and look how it
sits at this point in the boat as i move
through the image here it's always
tied to that place in the boat but if we
separate
this scratch from the boat it's going to
give it even more depth so i'm going to
hit p
for position and i'm going to go the
opposite way here i'm gonna bring this
really close to the camera like let's go
negative
1000. so now it's really close to the
camera
and because we did this we can actually
probably scale it back down
uh to something a little bit smaller
you know maybe something in here
so you can see now that it's created
even more depth right we've got more
parallax happening
more depth because this texture's here
in the foreground
now one thing i can do is to make this
texture a little more soft
is i can turn on depth of field for our
camera so i can hit a
a and i can turn on depth of field right
here by clicking this button
and it's on now we don't see a lot
happening because we need to play around
with some of our settings here so let's
do that so what i like to play around
with is typically this aperture
and i'm just going to crank it up to
something like 100.
so again now this is very soft so if i
turn the camera
depth of field off you can see it really
gets
crisp with these details even though
this image is really blown up but when i
turn the camera depth field on
there's there's texture there but it's
much more subtle
right so now you can see it kind of
looks like we have this like maybe like
some
some noise over the lens right there's
something there so
that's going to work for now
and let's next go in here to film strip
let's drop this in here i thought this
was really cool i really like the way
this looks
make it a 3d layer as well and let's
rotate this
uh 270 degrees sure scale we're going to
scale it
up a little bit and we actually uh need
to
before we do this let's just scale it up
slightly here maybe like 105
position let's bring it really close to
the camera like the other texture so
we'll go
negative 1000 and then
i just want to see the edge here so
let's position it here
and let's go
i don't know maybe let's go negative
here let's see if we can find something
interesting to look at okay so i really
like that a lot
that number
and let's make sure that we are
kind of keeping that film strip over
the whole time now maybe our camera
moves too far to the right i'm not sure
yet i'm not totally sold on this
uh maybe we'll bring it over like this
and let's make this guy the screen mode
and you can immediately see again it
looks like now we've got some like
overlaid
film textures which we do just kind of
gives it some more life here in the
foreground
we like that a lot let's close these
down
let's save our project next we're going
to bring in
some moving textures here from motion
science
this one is called uh film textures
dirt bring that over the top here let's
make it a
3d layer and actually let's go ahead and
set it back to screen
just like that p for position we're
going to bring it to
let's go negative 1000. let's scale it
way down because it is a 4k
image and if i solo this you're gonna
see
what it is it's just it's just dirt
right so i can see these kind of
splotches that pop up here
and they look a little blurry because we
have the camera depth of field on
uh so it's just some really interesting
splotchy
um film effects we're gonna make sure
that this
is in the screen the entire time
and you know i feel like my camera moves
a little too much
maybe so
[Music]
i really want the film strip to kind of
be lined up with the edge here
like so maybe even a little closer in
like that
and maybe the camera move here
doesn't start quite so far over so maybe
it's somewhere up in here
yeah i think that's working and let's
make sure that this
is in the frame the entire time so we
need to scale it up
just a little bit more maybe in there
now something i want to do here is like
when i see it right here
i want to play around with the with the
color correction of this blotch here
so if i solo that go to effect color
correction curves
all i have to do is bring down this
white level um
maybe somewhere in here and it makes it
sit just a little bit nicer here in the
composition so this is with
and without
yeah so it's a very subtle effect but it
gives it some
some life at certain moments so if i
preview this let's take a look at it
okay so there's what we got so far you
can see it's some really interesting
depth because we've been adding textures
over the top we've got that action vfx
footage in the background that's giving
it
this cinematic motion quality
that's bringing life to a still
photograph right by adding this footage
back here
it's bringing some life to this
photograph so let's add some more a
couple more elements here
from action vfx let's go up here to the
project
and let's find what i'm looking for here
which is right here lens dirt 8.
it's a texture they've got i thought it
was really cool
and i'm going to make it 3d position now
this one i'm not going to go all the way
back to a thousand
i'm going to go somewhere maybe around
800
or so and i'm also going to
scale this guy down
oh somewhere maybe in here and then hit
p
for position and
bring this guy over in here maybe
you know that's kind of interesting up
in here i like that a lot
let's also duplicate this guy
and let's bring another one
maybe over here on this side
something like that and let's set both
of these
to screen
so now you can see with and without
right so they bring this
this kind of they bring a lot of
atmosphere again so we've got
we're building these textures upon each
other
and at the same time they're creating
additional depth
because we've got our camera in here
really digging what's going on here next
let's bring in
some close fog let's do this this is
from action vfx as well
and we're going to set this
to a 3d layer and there's our fog
and we are going to if i can stop
opening up premiere for some reason
somehow keep clicking on that back here
in after effects let's set this
to screen as well
and let's uh let's scale it up a little
bit
let's hit p for position let's go so
these are negative 700 maybe this one's
at negative
500 ish somewhere in there and i'm
letting my 80d go here
so i can just get these kind of laid out
for you
in a quick manner otherwise i'll be
sitting here all day
uh let's see here let's move
this guy around a little bit
maybe in here so what i'm looking for
here is just some very subtle
fog up here near the foreground and you
can see it here
so let's see if we can see it in motion
so i'm just rendering a little section
of it here and i can't really see that
close fog right i know
if i if i get the settings right i can
bring some interesting visual interest
here to the foreground
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select close fog effect
color correction curves and i'm going to
bring curves in and i'm going to set a
point
around up in here kind of bring up those
black values
bring down those white values
and you can see what it does it really
just brightens up that fog
and i want to see so i can definitely
see it more now
so let's preview this and see how it
looks
so there's the close fog it's it's very
um it's very hard to see right it's very
very hard to see
um i think if i was to kind of play
around with a little bit more like i can
see
that fog there i can see it just moving
um
let me just kind of drag it down here a
little bit more see if i can
maybe not
clear on this a little bit more
i mean it's real real subtle the thing
that's bothering me at this point
is when i see these flickers this film
grime come on
it's just a little too in your face and
that's something we have to be
aware of when we are adding textures we
won't don't want to overdo it
so i'm actually going to drop down the
size of this a little bit more
and let me drag this over
something like this
actually i gotta increase the size again
just a bit
and then maybe
i'm gonna blur this out just a hair
let's go to blur and sharpen and
gaussian blur
and let's just give it maybe like
actually let's go like a three
just a little bit of a blur there i like
that
next let's bring in one more texture i
know we're bringing in a lot of textures
here
but let's bring in one more texture this
is film textures matte this is from
motion science as well
and we're going to hit p for position
actually let's make it
3d
like so scale
and this is a 4k element so let's scale
it down
quite a bit because i want to see it
here on the edges
let's go to set this to multiply
like so and let's also hit p for
position let's bring it to
negative 500.
i want to see the bottom edge just like
that so it kind of gives it this
interesting framing
down here now something to watch out for
is this line here
so if i bring it over like that yes i
don't want the line to overlap
the numbers here i really like how the
numbers look
and i gotta watch again the bottom frame
here
that's working pretty nice one thing we
can do here
to give it a little bit more life and to
kind of help bring some of these
elements off and on and give it even
more depth
is i can hit a a and for my focus
distance here i can actually add
an expression and we are going to alter
option click on focus distance and we're
going to type in wiggle
and we're gonna put in the values three
comma
two thousand so that says three times
per second
you are going to wiggle at or you're
going to change the focus distance a
value of two thousand that can be a
positive two thousand or a negative two
thousand so
we had our focus distance if i turn it
off our focus distance was set to 1857.
so i'm telling the camera you can go up
to 38.57
or you can subtract 2000 which would be
what negative something below zero
so if we preview this let's check out
what it's going to do you can see
immediately
the some of these elements are in focus
to begin with
and now they're kind of going out of
focus a little bit
now they're back in focus very quickly
there's a quick
shift of focus there it goes really out
of focus and we have to watch that
because we don't want to be too out of
focus
so hopefully it comes back in here here
it comes it's coming back in
that's looking pretty good
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
preview this
yeah and so you can see right there it
just it's just a little bit too much
of a pull of focus there so so we're
just going to continue to preview here
looking at the the details how often it
goes
you know out of focus how far does it go
out of focus is it too much
it's very important that we kind of you
know do pay attention to these things
like i do feel like it's maybe going out
of focus too much
at this point so let me go ahead and
finish it and we'll come back
so there we go it's looking pretty cool
it's too much of a focus
pull when we get to a couple points here
like right here it's too much
and right
there it's too much so what we can do is
we can try and dial back
2000 we can maybe try 1000
and see how that looks
and there's our preview and i really dig
that
it's looking pretty cool to me i could
tweak this all day long
and maybe i would try i like it when the
focus goes
very quickly out of focus the camera
goes very quickly out of focus and comes
very quickly back in
which we were getting at before but it's
just too extreme
so maybe i'd try having it do a little
bit more like maybe
four and i'll check that in the next
preview but before we do
check that let's actually stop here and
let's finish out this piece
what would i do here to finish this is
i'll put an effects layer at the top
which is pretty typical of what i do and
i'm actually going to use a sapphire
plug-in here that i
absolutely love and it is called
film effect and it just does an amazing
job
sapphire's got some really awesome
presets built into it so i absolutely
love sapphire
most pros i use i know are using
sapphire
for their own work and i don't remember
the exact filter i picked
if i go through these really quickly
here i mean you can see there's just
some really nice ones
and i think it was actually this one
right down here called star
field i'll load that in let us do his
thing
yeah i like that a lot now there's a
little bit of
blown out or not blown up but really um
some of the fog here i think is maybe
overdoing it a bit
so if i take that out yeah you can see
we lose a lot of the contrast here
uh so let's bring this fog
in front of our film matt like so
and let's also take the transparency
down a bit
something like that let's preview this
also keeping in mind that we changed our
wiggle expression here for depth of
uh focus distance um and before i
preview it i actually want to tell you
guys if you don't have sapphire i'm
gonna save this really quickly
if you don't have sapphire something you
can easily do here
is you can go into color correction
lumetri color and play around with some
of the creative uh filters here
there's some nice blue ones uh maybe
something like blue steel
is nice and then you can you know take
down
the intensity kind of get a mix in
between
you could take up the faded film you
could take down the saturation
uh you could play around the shadow
tents and and highlights and things like
that
you can also get a really nice look this
way so don't feel like you have to use
sapphire film effect it's just one of my
plugins i really like to use and i'm
going to preview this
getting close getting real close we're
getting real close here a couple things
i want to change here
this is what it's all about it's all in
these details right to finalize this
piece to make it look even better
i'm going to go with four and two
thousand i know we started with three
in two thousand but i think four and two
thousands gonna get it just right
and this texture is really bugging me
here this one's just
too powerful so we're gonna go to effect
color correction and we're gonna go to
levels here
and we're gonna bring in
our values something like this with the
blacks
and bring some of the gray so we're just
reducing the amount of texture we see so
width levels
and without so you can see it's a lot
more subtle this way
and really cleans up the image i mean it
was really bothering me it was too much
texture
right now maybe it's not quite enough
texture
this is that balance game you got to
play
just want a little bit there and let's
double click
on that's really nice lens dirt up there
from action vfx
i'm gonna bring in this one just a bit
kind of bring some dirt over the top
here and you can see what it does to
this
the smoke back here it really kind of
blends it into the background
really helps a lot
and then the other thing is this this um
texture mat here again it's just a
little too much
for me so i'm trying to minimize some of
it
and it might be that the camera move is
a little bit
too much i'll tell you what let's go
ahead and save
and before we preview this one last time
here let's change
one more thing here which is under the
camera settings let's change it from
fast rectangle
to something in here now this is going
to increase the render time quite a bit
but it creates a much nicer depth of
field effect
so when the camera goes out of focus it
looks a little bit more realistic
fast rectangle has the the name for a
reason that's what the camera defaults
to
fast rectangle because it does render
very quickly
but when you're looking for something
that looks a little bit nicer
and you want to finish the piece out i
highly recommend that you switch
to one of the other presets besides fast
rectangle
and there my friends is our finished
piece
really happy with how it turned out it
shows what you can do with
still images some awesome footage from
action vfx
a couple textures from actionvfx some
textures from motion science
and all that jazz so if you enjoyed this
you're going to find even more courses
over at motionscience.tv thanks for
watching once again my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
you